سلاح بشع في صوره انسان اطلقت عليه قواته
لقب جنرال او جنرال يوم القيامه واطلق
عليه الغرب لقب الجنرال القادم من الجحيم
هو كابوس الغرب وشبح مرعب للجيش الاوكراني
وكل اعضاء روسيا موسكو الباطشه في حربها
الكبرى يامره بوتين فيرد سمعا وطاعه وتلك
الوداعه التي يطيع بها الاوامر تنقلب
لجحيم ملتهب على اعداء روسيا جعل ليلكياف
نهارا بصواريخه الصماء وقال مقولته
الشهيره لن ادعى اعداء روسيا يشربون
القهوه في الصباح لانه لن ياتي عليهم صباح
تصلب وجهه وتجمدت ملامحه واصبح لا يعرف
الرحمه احتفل الاوكرانيون بعد سماعهم نبا
اعتقاله وحاول الغرب اقحام اسمه في تمرد
فاغنرد ضد بوتا لعلهم يتخلصون منه
ويسترحون من راس الشيطان لتنفي وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه وتصبح الاخبار المتضاربه
من هو الجنرال
الذي اوكل اليه بوتين مهمه تدمير اوكرانيا
وهل حقا طحالف مع فيغنر وانقلب ضد بوتين
وتم اعتقاله لتعرف اجابه كل تلك الاسئله
تابع الفيديو للنهايه
استدعاء جنرال الجحيم تمر ثمانيه اشهر على
عمليه الدب الروسي في الاراضي الاوكرانيه
انفجار شديد يحدث في جسر كيارتش بشبه
جزيره القرم التابعه لروسيا الكرم لن
يعتبر الواقعه تعبيرا عن الطبيعه
الارهابيه الاوكرانيه حسب تصريحه ومسؤول
اوكراني بتلك الزاويه يعلن التحدي علنا
قائلا تفجير جسر كيتش هو مجرد بدايه وكل
شيء غير شرعي يجب تدميره بوتين يستشيط
غضبا ويامر قادته قائلا احضروا ليسيرك س
ليعلن الجيش الروسي ان سورفيكان والملقب
بشنرال الجحيم قد دخل حلبه الحرب
الاوكرانيه ليكلفه بوتين بنفسه بقياده
العمليات الخاصه على الاراضي الاوكرانيه
يبدا شرفك اولى عملياته بامطار كييف بمئه
صاروخ الروسي كحفل استقبال نعم صباح ملتهب
عاشته اوكرانيا ليخرج جنر جحيم بعد ذلك
ويعلق قائلا لن ادعى اعداء روسيا يشربون
القهوه في الصباح لانه لن ياتي عليهم صباح
يا الهي اي مصيبه وقعت عليك يا اوكرانيا
رائحه التسريبات الاعلاميه تزف
للاوكرانيين خبر اعتقال
لاتهامه بالاشتراك في تمرد فاغنار ضد
بوتين قياده تحتفل بالخبر السعيد من هو
ليحتفل الاوكراني والغرب بالتخلص منه وهل
تم اعتقاله فعلا الصيد في الماء العكر
وكان الغرب قد احترف رياضه الصيد في الماء
العكر ولا يريد تفويت الفرصه الذهبيه
للتخلص من كابوسه بوتان فبعد تمرد الذي
قاده زعيم قوه فاغنر يفجن بريجان ضد موسكو
والذي مات قبل ان يولد نشرت وسائل اعلام
غربيه ان الجنرال سورفيكان كان على علم
مسبق بما يخطط له قائد فاجنر هوهو انه اته
لجنرال الجحيم الروسي بالخيانه العظمى
الغرب يحاول ضرب عصفورين بحجر واحد فبعد
ذلك انتشرت انباء عن اعتقال سورفيكان
بتهمه الخيانه العظمى وايداعه سجن لفورد
في موسكو احتفل تركيا بالخبر ولكن الحقيقه
كانت عكس ما تمناه زيلينسكي وحلفاءه ولم
يدم احتفال كياف طويلا فقد نفت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه اعتقال سورفيكان اليكم
المصدر وهذه المره المصدر هي قناه الجزيره
والتي تتعارض مع سياسه روسيا فقد نفى وزير
او مصدر في وزاره الدفاع الروسيه للجزيره
نفى الانباء عن اعتقال الجنرال
نائب قائد العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا وشهد شاهد من اهلها ليؤكد
الكرملين ان الجنرال الروسي لم يكن على
علم بمخططات قائد فاجنر وانه لا يؤيد
التمرد المسلح ضد موسكو اما بالنسبه
لعلاقه الجنرال الروسي بيفاجنار فقد نشرت
صحيفه
كان يخطط لاعتقال لكبار قاده الجيش الروسي
ومن ض وزير الدفاع سرقه ليعلم حينها جهاز
الامن الفيدرالي الروسي بمخططات قائد
فاغنر قبل موعد تنفيذها بيومين وهذا ما
اجبر على التراجع عنها في اللحظه الاخيره
حقيقه جنرال الجحيم تم التاكد من ولاء
وكشف الخدعه الغربيه فلم يكن للجنرال
الروسي اي علم بمخططات او حتى اي تعاطف
معه ليظهر بنفسه موجها رساله الى قائد
محذرا من ان ما يفعله يصب في مصلحه اعداء
روسيا قائلا ادعوا قيادات ومقاتل شركه
فاجنر للتوقف العدو ينتظر اي توتر في
الوضع السياسي الداخلي لا يجوز اللعب
لصالح العدو في هذه الاوقات الصعبه على
البلاد قبل ان يفوت الاوان من الضروري
الالتزام باوامر الرئيس الروسي بتلك
الكلمات اسكت سولفي كان كل الافواه التي
تتهمه بالخيانه ولكن السؤال الان لك عزيزي
المشاهد هل ترى ان جنرال الجحيم سينهي
الحرب الاوكرانيه لصالح الدب الروسي كما
فعل في حرب القرم ام ان الغرب سيكون له
راي اخر
القاب مرعبه وتاريخ من الدمويه
جنرال يوم القيامه وجنرال هرمجدول
والجنرال القادم من الجحيم كلها القاب
لاحد شياطين الحرب المقاتل المتمرس سيرجي
سورفيكان صاحب الخمسه والخمسين عاما تاريخ
من الدمويه والقسوه ولد في مقاطعه
الجليديه عام 66 شارك في حرب افغانستان في
ثمانينيات القرن الماضي ولم يكن قد اكمل
18 من عمره كان له دور كبير في احداث
الانقلاب على ميخائيل اخر رؤساء الاتحاد
السوفيتي عام 91 وكان من اشد المعارضين
لتفكيك الاتحاد السوفيتي في ذلك الوقت قضى
فترتين في السجن بتهمه بيع اسلحه وقياده
طابور خامس ضد المتظاهرين الروس وشارك في
الحرب الاهليه في طاجكستان في التسعينات
كما شارك في الحرب الروسيه الشيشانيه
الثانيه وحرب سوريا واه على ضحايا الحرب
السوريه من المواطنين الابرياء دون
العسكريين ومن هنا اصبح مقربا اكثر من
الرئيس الروسي
خروج الشبح الى الضوء بدا سرفك بالظهور في
المشهد العسكري بشكل رسمي بين عامي
عندما تم تعيينه مديرا للعمليات في الجيش
الروسي وفي عام 2013 عين قائدا للمنطقه
العسكريه الشرقيه وفي عام 2014 شارك في
الحرب ضد اوكرانيا بشبه جزيره القرم التي
انتصر فيها الدب الروسي على القوات
الاوكرانيه وعلى دعم الغرب ضع صيته اكثر
خلال العمليات العسكريه الروسيه في سوريا
عام 2015 والتي قام فيها بضرب الضباط من
هيئه الاركان العامه ليقوده والهجمه
العسكريه بنفسه وبكل جراه وشراسه اتهمته
منظمات حقوقيه بارتكاب جرائم حرب في سوريا
واطلقت عليه قواته لقبت جنرال هار ماجدون
او جنرال الزمان لقسوته وكثره استخدامه
الاستراتيجيه الارض المحروقه في المعارك
تقلد العديد من الاوسمه الرفيعه في الجيش
الروسي مثل وسام النجمه الحمراء ووسام
الاستحقاق للوطن الدرجه الاولى والثانيه
كان الشخص العسكري الوحيد الموجود في
قائمه اكثر 100 شخص تثق بهم موسكو يوم
تعيينه قالت عنه مواقع روسيه ان بامكانه
كسر البيوقراطيه العسكريه في الجيش
والوصول الى بوتين
يعتبر الغرب
كابوسا يقلق منامهم وشبحا مرعبا لا يامنون
ضرباته القاسيه اما بالنسبه لاوكرانيا
فيوم تعيينه يعتبر يوما اسودا على
زيلينسكي والجيش الاوكراني ترقى لرتبه
جنرال في اغسطس عام 2021 ومنها بدا
عملياته في اوكرانيا ففي اقليم دومباس
حاصر القوات الاوكرانيه في جوريسكي وسيطر
على مدينه
قائدا للعمليات في اوكرانيا هل مهمته
بمئات الصواريخ والقذائف التي دمرت
اوكرانيا وشعلت الاوكران لا يعرفون صباحهم
من مسائهم قام بتطويق قوه الاوكرانيه في
مدينه
من اهم المدن الاوكرانيه هل علمت الان
لماذا احتفل الاوكرانيون عند سماعهم نبا
اعتقال ولكن هل تم اعتقال جنرال بجحيم
فعلا ام ان الاحداث ستلد لنا اخبارا اخرى
لتؤكد او تن